do all christians think the same
suggested by wig connick
probably not but let's find out stick
around till the end enjoy the episode
you're like well i want to love who i
want to love there's that attraction
it's like where do you draw the line
i'm a grown man i like little boys i
know you don't agree with that and i
know that it is the same
i like christian music
three two one
go
oh man some christian music is
good and some of it is lame
but that's the same with like any kind
of any genre music is the same way
i have to be like in a certain setting
or a certain mind state to listen to it
i kind of agree that some is good and
some is bad but i kind of feel like
60 to 70 of it is not good
or like exciting but maybe i'm kind of
traumatized because i could only listen
to christian music when i was a kid
so now i'm like that's relatable yeah
that might be part of it
two one go
[Music]
i mean i'm gay i'm from like a little
town in texas it's difficult to not
question your faith because you're
told that gay people can't be christians
or
christians can only follow these certain
rules that are set out so
for me when i started to grow and to get
a relationship
with christianity myself is whenever my
faith became stronger but
it was definitely difficult and i'm
still really going through that right
now
there were things that i felt like i was
born knowing that god loved me and that
god was good and then
when i came into the church a little bit
later there were some beliefs
because i'm queer so that
people were just like this is what it is
and you can't be this and like this
is not but the reason i'm in this line
is because
i never felt that from god
i still felt like he loves me
[Music]
i support the lgbt community
when we mention support it means to
accept
and i don't accept the lifestyles within
the community
but do i love them do i want the best
for them
i absolutely do do i think that we
should be mean to them in church do i
think that we should shun them from
church
no and i'm sorry that you guys had that
experience because that is
awful that is horrible no one should go
to a church and feel like you need to
run away from it
it's interesting though because the
thing that has hurt me
the most is actually the language with
which you're speaking which
is more confusing i think no one
actually shunned me
it was more like this more like i love
you but like god kind of wants to like
send you to hell i do have christian
friends who are
queer or gay and they're struggling
they're abstaining from the lifestyle
but the lgbtq community says there's
nothing wrong with that lifestyle
they're proud
of that status not remorseful or
trying to be aligned with what the bible
says about it
you are literally picking one part of
the bible that you believe
and throwing away everything else
there's like certain materials that
we're not supposed to wear there's
certain foods that we're not supposed to
eat
but we don't discriminate against people
who do that but we do discriminate
against people who literally just love
someone different
if you're gonna disagree with it you
also have to understand like
the weight of what you are asking a
queer person
to do when you look at someone and you
feel like they're attractive and you
have to
disagree with that part of yourself
every second of the day you have to tell
yourself
that's freaking wrong that's freaking
wrong at like every
second like you don't think that i
should i should not marry a woman that i
love
i'm not saying you should be alone i'm
saying at the basis of anything
i want you to be who god created you to
be and i know that for you
you're believing that i was created this
way to love this way
but i would actually wonder because
you're like well i want to love who i
want to love there's that attraction
but when i it's like where do you draw
the line when there's
i'm attract i'm a grown man i like
little boys i
am a person and i know that you don't
agree with that
but there are lines because
i know you don't agree with that and i
know that it is the same
i think the lgbt is like a huge topic
within the christian community
but it doesn't make it any worse than
like i drink and stuff and sometimes i
drink in excess which is the sin
um but it just doesn't get that's
normalized you know i mean like that
doesn't get attacked as frequently as
like a lgbt would the community would
you know what i mean
i just define support differently
i think you can completely support
somebody's right
to love and feel love without supporting
homosexual activity homosexual activity
is sinful raping a child is sinful
we can argue about what's worse or
what's more acceptable or what our
society has normalized
but the end of the day we all sin we all
sin in different ways
and none of those sins should be
celebrated none of those sins should be
condoned and all of us should be working
not to change who we are but to become
more like christ
[Music]
god loves
you got some explaining to do over there
it sounds great to say god loves
everybody and does and god
does love everybody but i don't believe
equally
he loves his own children more than the
others in the world
he would not send someone that he loves
truly
to hell he is love that's what his
embodiment is so i think it's impossible
for him to not
show love towards his children i don't
think it's there's varying degrees i
think it's all standardized against
everyone like everyone is left equally
go
[Music]
sorry i'll go on this one
i am married i've been married for
almost 10 years to a christian man
for me what i feel in the bible that god
describes as a christian family
is two people husband and wife who are
devoted to serving the lord together
and we need somebody to come alongside
us who is
helping us to pursue our purpose and our
calling in christ
it's totally possible and often happens
that
people of different religions or someone
who's a christian and that doesn't have
a religion at all
are able to still work together and are
able to still
help people grow in their faith i
totally agree that i could learn from
non-christians even benefit from
relationships with muslims buddhists or
other non-christians
but the bible is specific about not
being yoked
in marriage to unbelievers whether
you're a muslim
christian or a buddhist you find someone
who doesn't share that i think you're
missing something
core in that relationship which won't
work for any marriage
but the thing is uh when you break down
so many of the major religions
a lot of the tenets are the same and we
kind of believe the same thing
inherently but that's where i disagree i
think we're very different
in terms of what we believe that we may
have similar activities like going to
church or a mosque
but what i personally believe about
jesus is not shared with
other religions no one else agrees with
that
i am waiting to have sex until marriage
three two one
go
[Music]
i wish i could be over there but i can't
unfortunately i made some bad decisions
when i was younger
the people that i've been with prior
there's always a piece of me with them
you know what i mean like it's something
i can never get back
it kind of bums me out a lot because
it's like i wish i could have saved
myself
all the way until marriage um in all
aspects of physical relations
as far as sex goes i mean that
party sold but
i do think that as a christian i
should be dating to find someone to be
with long term or finding someone to
marry
and so part of that does involve
sometimes waiting a little bit longer
waiting longer to like have sex
and to like really be intimate so i
personally am actually not even
kissing until i get engaged which a lot
of people don't believe me about but i
had a two-year relationship and i
promise it
happened i didn't particularly like it
but
i just find so much
strength and closeness to god in
preserving
my physical expression of love for
people even though it's
very very far from easy it's something
i'm
so excited for to be able to tell that
person
i saved this the most intimate part of
myself
for you because god was the only one who
had a key to my heart
before this
yeah i'm not saying that i'm a good
person but i'm saved by faith in jesus
christ who forgives me of my sin i know
where i
place my faith and that's why i know
where i'm gonna go i don't know
it's hard to know exactly what
specifically
is considered the biggest sins that will
keep someone from going to heaven
especially for me when i
haven't put as much thought into it as i
should christianity is not
about just making sure you're checking
off all the boxes to go to heaven
i feel like that robs us of the heaven
that's present here on earth
all i'm responsible for is doing my best
every day
and i pray that i do that every day and
i think that's true for everybody
everybody is just responsible for their
best
[Music]
dude i feel like i could probably step
on every one of these
lines at a different point in my life
because i grew up a christian but like
changed so much over time uh if you want
to grow and evolve with us
yeah make sure you like and subscribe
let us know what you thought in the
comments below about all the prompts we
love when you guys are answering them
and we love to interact with you guys
and as always make sure you follow us on
instagram as well
we'll see you guys next time